- Les Ukrainiens ne cessent
d'arriver dans l
polonaise.
Des voyageurs bien malgré eux,
souvent chargés et fatigués.
L'angoisseeses nuits difficiles
se lit sur les visages.
Lentement, parfois avec
à l'étage et découvrent
e e e la générosité de
leurs voisins polonais.
- On ne dit pas "les réfugiés",
ce sont nos invités.
- Kuba Tchaikowsky ne compte
plus les heu l l l l l l l l l .
Fin février, il a été
l'un des premiers bénévoles
à accueillir les Ukrainiens.
KUBA
responsable de la logistique
- On ne veut pas
les stigmatiser, c'est
des gens qui fuient la guerre
du mieux possible.
- Des invités dont le sort
a ému bien des gens et mobilisé
beaucoup d'énergie rapidement.
gratuit, on a une "droguerie"
gratuite, on a la phphphonie
mobile gratuite, on a internet
grauit, on a les sanitaires
- Ici, les Ukrainiens peuvent
prendre nenenener des nouvelles,
permettre aux enfants de
souffler, dormir un peu en
Dans l'entrée de la gare,
e e e e véritable cantine où
l'on sert toujours des repas
chauds, et parfois avec
- Au début, les gens, ilseaeaeas
le hall de la gare.
Et, je trouve que c'était
totalement indécentqu'au 21e si,
des gens mangent par,,,,
à même le sol.
- Une attention qu
avec les horreurs imposées
aux Ukrainiee e e e e mère et
sa fille ont passé par la gare.
Elles te
d'obtenir un visa pour
le Ceueueueueur cousin est venu
de Toronto pour les aider à
des bons mots pour les Polonais
qui ont aidé sa famille.
enenenenenenenenenenenenenenenee
qu'on leur a offert,
même le transport gratuit.
Tout se passe mieux et v v v v .
La nuit dernière,
et sa nièce ont enfin dormi
sans crainte,sans les sirènes d.
Mais les missiletoujours sur l'e
et les trains
d'arriver en Pologne.
Kuba Czaj
des milliers d'autres gardent
donc leurs bras ouverts,
accueillent leurs voisins.
Un effort qui se veut aussi
- Ça va surtout nous souder
entre Polonais ensnsnsnsnsns.
C'est tout le contraire de ce
que l'homme qu'on ne veut pas
quoi! Il voulait nous désunir et
il a oe e e e e e e contraire.
C'est dommage qu'il y ait
autant de victimes civiles
Ici Yanik Dumont Baron,
anananananananada, Varsovi